good morning Hank it's Tuesday I want to
return to the subject of America's
fascinating the inefficient health care
system and I want to make a capitalist
argument for reform but first a brief
defense of capitalism ok so think of the
economy as a pizza the richest people
get the largest portion of that pizza
and the poorest people get very little
of it in fact in the u.s. the poorest
40% of Americans get less than 0.3% of
the pizza that's problematic don't get
me wrong but the cool thing about
capitalism is that thanks to innovation
and competition over time the overall
size of the pizza increases so even if
your percentage slice of the pie doesn't
increase you get more pizza this is
ultimately why you probably live in a
place with a refrigerator and your
great-grandparents probably didn't
essentially Hank over time free markets
create free pizza well it's not free
actually because innovation usually
means like increased use of
non-renewable resources and new damage
to the ecosystem but what are free pizza
but and this is very important the only
way to get that free pizza is to make
the world safe for innovation and
competition like you need innovators to
create refrigerators and then you need
competition to drive the prices down
besides creating free pizza this also
creates lots of jobs so yeah
unfortunately our healthcare system
sucks at facilitating this ok so in the
United States most people get their
insurance through their employers like
the vast majority of companies with more
than 50 employees offer health insurance
plans that's how my family and I get our
health insurance through my wife's job
but if you or your spouse don't work for
a big company it can be difficult to get
insurance at all because insurers can
deny people access to coverage based on
past health problems called pre-existing
conditions and this can lead to all
kinds of irrationality because people
don't want to risk this pre-existing
condition stuff so they either stay at
their job with a big company or they
remain full-time students because those
ways you're guaranteed to have health
insurance example in 2008 Henry Wright
graduated from college which meant he no
longer had insurance so he figured he
should enroll in graduate school in
physics so he could keep his insurance
even though what he really wanted to do
was do you to be stuff fortunately for
Henry at that very moment the Affordable
Care Act came along saying that he was
entitled to be on his parent's insurance
until he was 26 and that allowed him to
go work for a tiny online video company
which in turn led to the creation of
minutephysics and minute earth-2 of the
most innovative educational projects on
the internet telling us everything from
what a Higgs boson is to Y locusts
plagues happen those projects have been
watched hundreds
millions of times and they make us
smarter but they also increase the size
of the pizza but crazily if it hadn't
been for this weird rule in the
Affordable Care Act that you get to keep
your parent's insurance until you're 26
none of it would have happened let me
give you another example you and by you
I mean my brother angry and I don't mean
the other people watching this video
although hi Hank
you have altered of colitis a chronic
and very serious illness that's also
extremely expensive to treat so no
insurance company will ever choose to
insure you now thanks to the state of
Montana you currently have a so-called
catastrophic coverage plan which caps
your out-of-pocket health expenses at
ten thousand dollars per year that's not
ideal but before Montana passed that law
you couldn't get any health insurance at
all meaning that you were constantly at
risk of like a million dollar
bankrupting illness or injury so Hank
back before this government subsidized
health care plan came along you had to
allocate every dollar you made to the I
don't want to go bankrupt if I fall off
a ladder fund but then when the state of
Montana came along and forced insurance
companies to at least offer catastrophic
coverage to people like you you could
suddenly use your resources more
efficiently basically you could take all
that gosh I don't want to fall off a
ladder money and start spending it on
other stuff like I don't know dftba
records which now employs lots of people
or you could spend money to start VidCon
which now also employs lots of people
then there's the Lizzie Bennet diaries
and crash course and scishow and
sexplanations and the brain scoop and
the foundation to decrease worldsuck
and subbable and the juggernaut known as
2d glasses
Hank all together these investments that
you've made an innovation are
responsible for dozens of jobs and for a
significant growing of the overall size
of the pizza and none of that could have
ever happened without publicly
subsidized health insurance now of
course Hank could have gone to work for
a big company after college and it could
have gotten health insurance but then
there would be no nerdfighteria no
VidCon no dftba records etc career
decisions should be about finding the
place where your talents meet the
world's needs not about finding the
place where you can get health insurance
okay so this all took a hilarious turn
recently when Henry turned 26 and aged
out of his parents health care coverage
he then had to apply for his own
insurance and sure enough he was turned
down because of the pre-existing
conditions of tinnitus and tendonitis
that's right he has a little bit of
ringing in his ear occasionally and his
knee gets sore because he runs a lot
because he's so frakking healthy now of
course on January 1st 2014 Henry will be
eligible for coverage as everyone else
will be through the Affordable Care Act
but if that didn't exist he would be
forced to choose between minutephysics
and his health that is a ridiculous
choice and that ridiculous choice has
lived by tens of millions of Americans
has inhibited innovation prevented job
creation and it has made the pizza
smaller than it ought to be heck there
are only a few things that really pissed
me off in this world and one of them is
small pizzas so that's my capitalist
fiscally conservative case for health
care reform for too long we have
privileged employees over entrepreneurs
when we need entrepreneurs like Henry
and Hank to maximize economic growth
Hank thank you for being the engine that
drives job growth in the American
economy and for giving lots of people
jobs including me I will see you on
Friday
informational videos are allowed to be
more than four minutes long the whole
time dang it sorry you saw the secret
innards of the set which is really just
my desk